so we're gonna get started our next
speaker is Mark patashnik
who's a Ludwig chair of microbiology at
Memorial sloan-kettering Cancer Center
so mark is another giant of molecular
biology has made seminal contributions
in a number of areas particularly
understanding how genes are regulated
back in the 1960s we had an idea about
gene regulation based on sophisticated
genetic experiments but there was no
biochemistry so mark undertook some
audacious experiments of bacteria phage
lambda isolated the lambda repressor and
showed a bound DNA and repress
transcription this was the first site
specific DNA binding protein is very
exciting work and it's continued to
elucidate many of the central features
of gene regulation in gene expression
he's also shared his insights in a book
the genetic switch but his passion
extends beyond laboratory and many of us
in this room have had the pleasure of
hearing mark perform on his Stradivarius
violin so mark and meant saving they're
both working in medicines laboratory and
known each other for many years so I
just I believe that Sid knows Mark
really well so to introduce mark I will
quote Sid because
Sid invited mark several years ago and
he said and I quote our speaker today is
Mark potage nee a notoriously smart guy
and that you can see that from the title
of his talk Clark
Oh can I be hurt yes that's it no more
blahblah bounce it I mean enough is
enough
so yeah so years ago I went to my thesis
advisor Matthew meselson and I said man
I just heard a completely weird talk by
this guy who you think is a great guy
and matt said yeah well you don't
understand how he operates what he does
is he sits at home and speaks and films
a really clear detailed scientifically
proper talk then he gets on stage he
puts it in his brain gets on stage
clicks and then he comments on it as it
goes along that's why it's a little odd
so Tom said we drove over he said that's
what you should do so this talk is gonna
have some of that a lot of it you
already know or won't admit to not
knowing and so ok so originally I mean
the the Thicke specificity so why should
we think about that well one of the most
galvanizing things about jacoba domino
was that was specificity there was a
specific regulatory gene that regulated
a specific target gene so how does it
work
so of course one possibility was RNA on
either end and it would have been sort
of more commodious said it turned out
that way we could all have an RNA fest
but it didn't turn out that way and
although RNA is not completely
irrelevant in most cases it's a protein
and of course we immediately knew that
the protein would bind to a specific
site as defined by genetics as being
important and when all the huff and puff
was over we found out at heart what
determines specificity it's variations
on this very simple principle that an
alpha helix is in the major groove it
looks at the base pairs and so on now
that's a very thin and unreliable read
on which to base a whole regulatory
system because there's not much
specificity
there's very little binding energy so we
consult the Bible which is this
fantastic little book which nobody but
me seems to have read again very old
systems biologists call the sciences of
the artificial by Herbert Simon if you
don't get anything else out of this talk
go to Kendall and get it
third edition how to build a reliable
system from unreliable parts this is a
standard engineering problem and since
he thought biology should be regarded as
a design problem just like everything
else and he says we can cope with the
unreliability only by our manner of
organizing these parts so now you're
worried oh this is a famously elaborate
intellect mastering all kinds of fields
and so on so it's gonna get pretty
abstract pretty fast no he says the
requirements Herbert Simon the
requirements of design can be met fully
by a modest adaptation it's called
sciences of the artificial nine he kept
up with genetics which he made one in
the 60s he made it in the third edition
just before he died in the 90s so to our
relief he says the requirements of
design can be met by a modest adaptation
of ordinary declarative logic so let's
see how far that can get us well that
initial thing of course sorry man are
you gonna interrupt it what okay
so how does it work well the way it
works is by just the dumbest way
possible you take the basic reaction you
reiterate you invert your blah blah blah
and it starts to look like this you make
interactions between the proteins and
pretty soon you've increased the
specificity a huge amount now the
important point here is that it depends
on protein DNA interactions protein
protein interactions and that of course
when you get into the higher world of
where everything is can be very
confusing because proteins can go from
here to there depending on their binding
partner so the whole idea of sis
regulatory changes yeah they're
important but in East a lot of we know a
lot of stuff is not that it has to do
with the interaction of guys and then
the most scary thing is of course it
depends on concentration in matter I'll
come back to so this simple picture has
a bonus the bonus is that cooperativity
explains quote unquote gene activation
how a regulator can turn on as we say
transcription of a gene what we have to
do is just replace one of these dimers
with RNA polymerase in e.coli and we get
this sort of picture the polymerase is
binding the weak affinities their
promoter the activator binds and then
touches the polymerase and that
increases the rate of transcription not
at Cold Spring Harbor I got into a big
thing the past is always repeated by the
enthusiastic youth there is you know
where our years of arguments because you
can get a K be effective KD effect
doesn't matter in all these cases we
know from crystallography from genetics
that any contact between the activator
and the polymerase when they're both in
their positions will do this thing
called activate namely make the
polymerase come and transcribe more
frequently and as I say the the key
experiments are that you can change
these contacts there's nothing special
about a region that such as polymerase
just a couple of amino acids it's the
dumbest possible way to run the universe
and it turns out that's how it works in
eukaryotes too
in a way even simpler because it's
slightly but what it really doesn't
matter to a large extent no matter I'll
come back to let's see how do you get a
pointer out of this yeah so this little
guy here who is a DNA binding domain of
any type attached to what's called an
activating region will activate and the
amazing thing is it activates any gene
in any organism as far as tested so
sometimes things are pre bound and
people don't understand this and then it
will recruit what you need to do the
rest of it it plants Tom and I have
showed the flies plants all kinds of
stuff and so we this still is a slightly
miraculous business and it's not being
studied very much Steve Hahn is one of
the people and he knows it touches and
apparently changes its configuration and
so and so forth and somehow it triggers
this assembly of a hundred proteins or
whatever it is and transcription and
let's remember one of Jacoby Munoz rules
the question is how you regulate
transcription not happen not what
happens as you transcribe because people
right we'll come back to what we do
about nucleus ohms in a minute and the
important point is that the conceptual
the evidence for this is just as in
bacteria you can many different
activating regions it's actually simpler
many different activating regions work
if you put in artificial protein protein
contacts it works it's incredibly easy
to get it to go to work it so evolution
has no problem doing this moreover as
you might have guessed from these kinds
of pictures any activator can a works on
just depends on ah finally the word
specificity is - meaning which gene is
activated just depend domain so if you
put the thing in front of one gene to a
first approximation and activates that
gene put it in front of another gene it
activates that gene so evolution is
working with basically a logo type set
it's almost embarrassingly simple
and for example one of the things you
can do is to put the activator next to
its own gene so you'll get a positive
feedback loop and in fact that's how it
works in lambda to make a lie Sigyn this
thing is making this thing which is
unfortunately called a repressor but
it's activating here the cells divide
and divide and this is incredibly stable
an incredibly stable differentiated
state if I may use that word and just in
case you might want to hear this yeah
because the cells are dividing the
repressor level the repressor activator
level can fluctuate so to guard against
that you introduce negative feedback
which either increases the rate or
decreases the rate as needed a governor
so but there's nothing fancy about this
there's another thing that Simon goes
into you know how how would you
calculate how to do this if you and well
you can't calculate but if you if you
just fiddle around with a with a binding
site and make it of the appropriate
affinity you will get this effect people
can interrupt me a thing and it turns
out much to ones pleasure that this is
the way it almost certainly well it
certainly works in certain high
organisms and maybe all so for example
here's Ho Birds famous picture of a worm
neuron which was a gene which is a
transcriptional activator it's got a
binding site nearby so it's turning
itself on and it as it turns on these
other guys and the amazing fact is that
if you interrupt this loop in many of
ways different ways the differentiated
state goes away and there was a review
citing I don't know there are lots of
key yes
so the mystical stuff about chromatin
states and so on is even more silly than
it used to be okay now this is
maintenance that I've just described
maintenance of the differentiated state
how do you get there well the way you
get there
is by establishment and that's a huff
and a puff that's that's what you get
real so for example in sea urchins
according to the late Eric you get this
kind of thing which is like a thousand
lambdas all all mixed up that is sea
urchin let's see I can tell by just
looking it oh it ends up making
activators that then self activate and
maintain the differentiated state that's
what differentiation is getting the
right activators that auto according to
this view which has evidence actually
you you have to do this and make these
different cell types which will then
make different auto activators that
perpetuate themselves and here you're
not dividing because you're
differentiate you're differentiated so
you don't need the negative feedback
okay
most developmental processes don't work
most embryos don't make it
no no because what do you mean I mean
there are too many ways to interfere
what I suggest a man who always poo-poos
it is that the reason you age is that
these positive feedback loops with a
certain frequency get lost
and you can't get them back without
going through this some kind of process
right so of course you would just blow
them pretty soon so Matt will say well
yeah but what causes the loops to anyway
in lambda it we thought used to think
this was complicated I don't want to go
into the details because I'm gonna get
to the underlying point in a minute but
it's this sort of thing you you but just
so you can understand it you know the
phage comes in it makes an activator
that works like any old activator it
goes here and makes this thing called
the repressor which then feeds back and
turns itself on and these are off now
and so you have a self maintaining state
so this is the equivalent from here to
here is establishment and the other
thing is maintenance
okay so far the principles of everything
that I've talked about I would argue are
general and they apply to bacteria and
to youa carry-outs
and surprisingly now nucleosomes that I
so I don't want to you know we spent
three years on this or something
developing a new essay to tell how you
see there was this big business where
people would calculate fancy models for
where nucleosomes were bound and it was
just all in my opinion totally
irrelevant and misleading it goes like
this nucleus sums form at random but if
you regard them as DNA binding proteins
and measure their affinities of this
special assay you find that the higher
the GC content that tighter they are
bound
now the non-intuitive aspect of this
actually we don't even know why that's
true at least I don't Roger
explain that anyway the GC effect of
that GCC's good okay so here's something
I think Roger suggested years ago
phasing the precise positioning of
nucleosomes is a completely independent
variable it has to do with barriers so
if you have a barrier so the nucleosomes
can't move it doesn't matter whether
they're binding tightly or weakly this
is quite contrary to what - how typical
DNA binding proteins work right the
tighter they bind the more they're going
to be precisely positioned with
nucleosomes it doesn't matter they they
have blah blah blah but if they run into
a barrier I'll try an example they tend
to face and everybody was trying to
figure out from the sequence why they
face of course it was all hopelessly
wrong so let me tell you now what I
think are three good news aspects of
random nucleus information first of all
of course everyone I think agrees that
it expands the ways you can do
cooperativity so if two guys compete for
the same nucleosomal DNA under the in
the same nucleus ohm
they'll of course help each other even
if they don't touch and bacteria they
have to touch but here you've gotten
right and there are variations on this
one guy can have an active anyway
doesn't matter but that's good and that
partly explains why you carry out seem
like such a mess I mean you get these
guys who are binding cooperatively you
know all over the place so what I didn't
know wow I had no idea that was going to
happen okay now here here's something
I'll never convince people of the great
news about even though sometimes people
say it they don't understand okay you
don't need in hire you and eukaryotes
promoter occluding repressors let me
give you an example of why you do need
them or why you need them in bacteria in
bacteria this recruiting reaction is of
course it's a factor of 10 whatever it
is and this if you take away the
activator the flim race will give you a
significant basal level of expression
the only way you counter that basal
level is by adding a repressor and in
fact to my knowledge all activators that
work this way and bacteria are paired
with repressors so there's something
called lamb depressor working as an
activator and CRO there's a cap and Lac
repressor and on and on so the idea is
that when you the fact that you get
these huge factors of induction just
using binding interactions which either
push up the basal level or push it down
and as you know as your kovin minoo just
doesn't really matter but the only thing
they knew about were the repressors and
so it's another story but in fact in
eukaryotes you just don't need them let
me give you an example so here's an
example of the gal genes that we studied
a lot and so before you induce there's
an inhibitor actually on gal for these
nucleus ohms that lie in the promoter
are actually rather weakly bound
to other nucleosomes because it's sort
of a high eighty but it doesn't matter
the basal level is zero
there's no repressor there's no people
get confused about glucose which will
never be understood but under ordinary
conditions the gene is totally off and
these nucleus are sitting here now
when you activate which means remove the
inhibitor what you find is that a a
protein called switch sniff is recruited
and you can watch with this special
assay the nucleosomes falling off and
the DNA becomes ever more free of these
nucleosomes except in the center here
which is a another story but let's leave
that aside for the moment if you mutate
switch sniff you simply don't activate
they actually you do but it takes a day
instead of 20 minutes almost every
affective molecule psychology that we
ever study you say it doesn't happen
it's in the literature and so on it does
happen if you wait long enough but the
whole point of these things is to make
it happen so the obvious point is that
these new although it and it's also well
known that if you disturb nucleosomes in
general you start to get basal
transcription so it's it's hard to avoid
the conclusion that the random semi
specific let's call it visit or a
binding of nucleosomes is repressing the
basal level and by that I mentioned
these guys are phased only because
there's a barrier here if there weren't
a barrier and we know that if we take
this barrier and put it anywhere else in
the genome we get phase nucleosomes
they sometimes they bind much more
tightly and so on it doesn't matter it's
a completely independent variable so
let's see though I leave anything out
so for example then if we want to look
in a higher eukaryote we look at the
purine Mouse kit gene and in myeloid
cells the gene is off and this large
region is covered with nucleus ohms and
these have a lower affinity which may or
may not be important for the promoter
which lies 150
KB away which is into CPG Island and
therefore these nucleosomes are bound
very tightly now if you go to mass cells
where the gene is active
these nucleosomes are largely displaced
you get this
these proteins binding looping as I'll
show you in a minute which everyone
agrees now does an amazing thing it's
just like in yeast it displaces a
nucleus ohm or two and puts in the
machinery and now by the way you'll
notice that these nucleosomes are
seriously phased that's because of the
barrier of the machinery that's been
imposed before that they're not fazed at
all so there's nothing to do with the
sequence seklir goodness Eckler do you
care no okay so just to reiterate it in
eukaryotes removal or inhibition of an
of the activators whatever they are
suffice it to turn the gene totally off
and that's not true in bacteria so then
you say so what it's a minor point well
yeah I already mentioned about
cooperativity I don't know why this has
come up again about the nucleosomes but
what is the important point oh yes I'm
now down to number three that's it
so I've already said cooperativity is
expanded thanks to nucleus ohms
you don't need repressors patient of
nucleosomes and now something that Mike
Levine almost said you now have a
different logic you can have here's an
enhancer that works from a distance it
loops over and activates this gene so
how do you turn that off well you turn
it off by decommissioning as we say this
enhancer you take away these activating
proteins so now what happens well the
gene goes off but it can be activated by
proteins bound to any other enhancer if
you did it the way bacteria did it and
put a repressor here you couldn't
activate from any of these from yeah
from the other guys so this is the
secret that enables
karates to use multiple alternate
enhancers to activate genes which
modestly put is the secret to life does
anyone object on it is it clear and I
was just showing you an example or two
so here for example are the mast cells
and this is the Kip gene and here you
see a huge peak of polymerase the gene
is on like crazy and it's got these huge
this is called a super enhancer which
doesn't mean anything there are four
peaks of a combination of three things
there's RNA polymerase in every peak
there's in two different histone
modifications frankly I always forget
where they are because there's there's
absolutely no underst so this is also
got a - alright but you can measure
these you can detect enhancers by the
coincidence of pol - and these marks and
you know need I say it we have
absolutely no idea what the marks do
some people claim the marks come in
after transcription has begun their
little little transcription of these
guys now let's go to gist which is a
tumor gastrointestinal stromal tumor and
of course the mast cell enhancers are
totally off and now there's a new
enhancer here upstream this one has 3
peaks and the gene is on but not quite
as much so in the tumor you're
activating from a different set of cells
and different set of enhancers and in
the Maya in myeloid cells where the gene
is totally off there just aren't any
enhancers negative effect you don't need
negative effects if you got rid of it
the activators okay so then just to make
the point with a slight something else
is it the way the enhancers communicate
with the promoters as as it happens in
lambda M is by DNA looping so but
there's an added something here so here
we go back to the mast cells with these
four peaks of Paul - and so
and the Gina's on like gangbusters now
what if we add shrna to red 21 well
transcription goes down a lot and
confusingly these enhancer Peaks go down
and this and many other suggestive
experiments indicate that these guys are
somehow talking to each other
notice what happens in between here and
here and here and here we don't really
understand that but it's probably
there's some cooperativity involved in
formation of these enhancer Peaks and
you'll notice that transcription is
going down I'll just say what are the
thing in case I don't get to it am i
doubt a time yet ah okay one it doesn't
look like so much on this slide but I
just want to say it so when you go from
on to less on if you go from on to off
there's nothing as I showed you if you
go from on to less on here are the
polycomb marks suddenly appearing so
okay I'm gonna come back to that just
ask me about that it's easy to make
enhancers so for example in doing a
maraca reprogram experiments we compare
Sox versus sux vp-16 which is sux fused
to an activating region and what's
amusing is you can make new enhancers
that never existed and their higher
Peaks when you have Sox vp-16 the
stronger activator than when you have
that and then I could go through a whole
bunch of stuff where you eliminate you
make super enhancers you can destroy
super enhancers and so on so that's how
you regulate genes one way or another
you inhibit the activators it's very
easy to make enhancers of course there
are a lot of details we don't understand
but you don't do it by repressing the
gene that's what makes everything
possible now so here's the big picture
and some of you have heard me
about this before none of this is
surprising not at nothing I'm saying
about well I got to be a little careful
not and I think this makes the role of
nucleosomes I've been discussing puts it
in a in a context so first of all
obviously the term gene regulation is
silly genes aren't regulated what's
regulated is RNA polymerase so that it
goes to one gene versus another and when
you think about it that way you realize
that almost all enzymes non-classical
enzymes enzymes that are not involved in
seeing small molecules but rather other
large molecules are regulated this way
regulated meaning substrate choice is
determined by recruitment so the famous
example I always like to use is e 3 E 2
sorry which has a lot of possible a lot
of possible substrates so just notice
the enzyme is constitutively active this
is true for a lot of these inter
secondly there's a certain natural
tendency to work everywhere it's part of
the background that's a problem that's
what nucleosomes help us with in
transcription there's another way of
helping us here the way you get
specificity is of course by recruitment
you use these little things called III s
which are entirely equivalent to
transcriptional activators they simply
bind to the enzyme and to the specific
target this one binds to the green
target as any fool can see and I just
want to emphasize that s one looks into
this you see that every single enzyme
there are these a different and
sometimes quite unexpected ways that
Nature has fought the background problem
so in your BIC relation I'm told that if
you do just a little chain doesn't do
anything gets erased by if you do a big
chain then whatever
there's an amazing story about kinases
and of course there are fossa
then you get D ubiquitinated there of
course there phosphatases have countered
kinases but there are more sophisticated
ways always so that when you get a
little bit of it you you erase it always
fighting against the basal level because
all these enzymes are constitutively
active and it's just a question of of
mass action who they're going to work on
very it's amazingly dumb way to run the
university you would think if you were
to design it but that's the way it works
the amazing thing is not aging the
amazing thing is that it all works in
the first place and for example one of
the things that could go wrong and my
cancer pills are not impressed ever by
this except they keep discovering it
that if you over produce anything you
love a person enzyme a substrate or a
recruiter any of these things you will
tend not merely to turn up a pathway you
will turn you will tend to lose bests
officially so for example this is
appearing all the time now
Sawyer's at Sloan found the amazing
thing that the androgen receptor and
prostate cancer it's on so he kept
developing these inhibitors and more and
more fighting completely wipes out the
tumor so that the because the androgen
receptor wants to bind to these DNA
binding sites and activate certain bad
genes but he always ends up with
resistance and what are the resistance
there over productions of the
glucocorticoid receptor which now binds
to the antigen binding sites you see
this with kinase I have a amazing thing
about the pi3 kinase pathway where they
get resistance and bla bla on this off
then BOOM and what has happened is that
now you're over producing some other
kinase which of course since it's just a
matter of binding a factor of 10 or
whatever it goes to the wrong substrate
so they always say well we're activating
this pathway yeah but it you see what I
mean in other words the way the whole
thing works you've got to maintain
specify
of these inherently not very specific
enzymes they all have the active same
active site after all like kinase is for
example the phosphor there you get the
idea and so this is this makes the
cancer thing even more depressing should
I say we do it well here or less okay I
was gonna make a nod why don't you ask
me if you want to hear about this
otherwise I'll just skip it thank you I
have two comments in the initial part of
your talk and maybe throughout you
talked about the need for just an amino
acid or two to touch another protein and
that was sufficient but let me point out
to you those couple amino acids are in
an architecture which is specifically
arranged and they're in
three-dimensional space so it's far more
complex in the simplicity it's a simple
you know it's really complex first real
demonstration of this we had was a
mutation in a member of the what's it
called call gal lemon and it had
acquired a mutation that now did an
interaction it wasn't supposed to do
okay it's a very you know so now you
take just a small sliver of that protein
stick it on to any other protein that's
it you know - yeah and it works so the
only problem is to expose these well
it's a question of presentation it's
being presented by another protein so
that that's my point
it's a now let me get on to this is a T
biological question or it's a point it's
not for you I
I hope there's people in the audience
that have thought about this but it just
so happens the diameter of an alpha
helix is the same as the diameter of the
major groove in DNA so the question is
how many other protein motifs were
explored before nature settled on the
Alpha helix you know is any one study
and you know is that other millions well
I know these other motifs but ones that
have this regulatory ability to bind DNA
specifically there are millions of
motifs and not all of them fit this
simple you know like the homeobox in
like lambda present helix-turn-helix ah
something yep yeah there are multiple
ways of binding the major groove DNA to
touch the basis to discover the sequence
so it turned out that way with the alpha
helix but I doubt if they were
correlated I think it's unlikely that
those two events happen together forming
DNA and alpha helix YZ they were not
coordinated I mean the implication of
what you say yes but I'm saying that the
proteins found plenty of other ways of
doing it so might say after all for
intelligent design because if you're
gonna make the Alpha helix
I mean and it fits in the major always
thought it was miraculous all
intelligent designs once that was yeah
once the alpha helix was found you know
it was us repeatedly made for many
interactions with DNA you know
genetically once it was found but I mean
I don't know
well yeah you're right so the talons are
a magnificent example they stick a
finger in and it's like zinc fingers and
so on yeah yeah so maybe life would
exist even if it weren't true
within a sequence-specific dna-binding
protein based on the earlier knowledge
of globular protein structure and the
way in which substrates enter a groove
in the protein and so for he came up
with the idea of separating the strands
for recognition so that the basis could
enter a general model for the structure
of higher organisms where was it nature
Jim Watson told me I've been looking for
it because Jim wants I know what the
argument is I just never saw the paper
no further Jim told me that Crick went
to bed for three weeks when he saw what
the real answer was I'd love to find
that paper can you send it to me great
mm-hmm I've heard about it I just can't
find it I have this great quote from
Crick that I used it a college talk
recently to try to get some reactions
from students and I said you know you
people are all too passive you don't
want to criticize each other and I put
up a statement a magnificent statement
from Crick saying if you're gonna do
science seriously there is no most no
way you will not go down the wrong path
unless you have someone there to tell
you you know and so then I put up a
picture of Wally Gilbert I said I found
this guy told me how foolish every day
and that was incredibly useful but
that's not the culture now right and men
of course
that's also true yeah but there's none
well if they are most students now never
heard of Kokomo No so why would they be
influenced by any of that oh come on I
can tell you what's in the textbooks is
complete you know you read about gene
regulation now and it's just like
fairyland actually there are two books
you know apparently yeah well I've
always said I think Tom gets entirely
too much credit for all the things he's
done after leaving my lab I mean do I
get any credit for that no forget that
never mind so y'all buying it okay
you